please allow me to introduce myself I'm
a man of wealth and taste
I've been around a long long year stolen
many man's soul and fate I was around
when Jesus had his moment of doubt pain
I made damn sure Pilate washed his hands
and sealed his faith pleased to meet you
hope you guess my name loving you is the
nature of my game I hung around Saint
Petersburg when I thought it was time
for a change
I killed the Czar in the minister's
pleased to meet you hope you guess my
name loving you is the nature of my game
right Timothy yes Timothy where you from
originally where'd you grow up Chicago
Illinois tell me what child did he had
both your parents growing up yes
my dad was Chicago police officer he was
honest and upright and he was a heavy
drinker of alcohol but he could handle
it
and you know he got shot three times
with an m14 by a maniac who got
committed to the nuthouse for life
because the guy he just kept every week
he just shot somebody the guy was nuts
so they committed him to the mental
asylum and he when he got shot he made
me throw away three prescription bottles
of pill and I guess they were pain pills
and he used Jack Daniels and vodka to
kill the pain that's what he did do
interesting great man
see your childhood was good yes wasn't
bad at all
and then when F tur you left your
parents house where'd you go with them
to Phoenix Arizona how was Phoenix too
hot for me
130 degrees every day and then at night
138 or 140 the Sun Goes Down and gets
hotter if you're not born there you
can't get used to it
so for drugs a part of your life no and
I read not until I got to high school
and then there was all kinds of drugs
and you know you had to go to a bad
neighborhood to get him and you know
there was fun drugs like mescaline pink
organic mescaline and a capsule $2 for a
pill and you just sit there and you see
colors and your ear happy yeah you see
in colors and you're happy it's not that
bad right you know you're not scared
you're not seeing monsters or anything
like that you just see in colors and you
got a a body hi so for two bucks it was
wasn't bad how about today are you still
using anything no I don't use anything
you drink though I do I drink beer yeah
I like vodka once in a while but not
every day see when I lived in Phoenix
they have a place called local alcohol
reception center and the police bring a
min if they find street drunks but you
can go there yourself and they give you
Librium and Librium is lesser than
valium I worked at Eli Lilly drug
company in Chicago and I thought I'm
gonna have access to drugs now and I
that was not to see but it
they paid good and they gave me a
company car and a standard gas station
credit card he gave it to me so that
wasn't bad a Chevy Malibu station wagon
Burgundy what jobs that you had
throughout your career telemarketing
that's what I do
LA Times Orange County edition that that
taught me
what the mortgages I want to mission
priority lending I went to some other
company I can't Oh Howard Weil LeBeau
and Fredriksson so you sell loans or
whatever over the phone over the phone
yeah
that's all I did over the phone work you
how old it 64 65 board for 1155 well 65
come April and April's right around the
corner yeah so you live in LA now yeah
and you ever married no never married no
kids no no married no kids no kids and
sometimes you'll have come down here to
skid row and pick up some of the ladies
oh yeah like whenever I can how often is
that whenever I feel like it and I feel
like it every day oh yeah so you're here
multiple times a week
yes multiple times a week yeah and you
have picked different different women
that you'll pick up or different ones
yeah I know the good way I can look at
them and see what's happening right you
know where will you guys go you'll go to
a motel we'll talk first and you know
get to meet each other and then I'll
take her out for whatever she wants to
do eat she wants to eat I'll take her
for food via dinner breakfast lunch
whatever she wants and you'll spend the
night with her or just just a little I
usually go to a motel 6 and it's
affordable it's cheaper yeah they're
cheap you know I can't I can't afford
hundred dollars for one day hundred
dollars a night
yeah well motel 6 is 40 bucks you get
day and night not bad yeah so you're
doing oral sex or intercourse or what
kind of stuff well she does oral sex on
me and then intercourse you know are you
using condoms when you do this oh yeah
nowadays you need a condo because you
never know what the hell they got once I
get to know her if I know her for a
month or so then I know her then I don't
need a condom because
I know she's not [ __ ] around she's
not doing nobody else yeah what's the
price range for for these services
what's the most and what's Elise
well you you know for the knockout babe
you know mom
born and raised in Chicago knockout baby
on Rush Street I've got you know they
want they want crack they want to smoke
crack they want a snort crack they want
a snort coke they those kind of ladies
yeah and they want money and those are
$500 and you got to have the money or
they going with you yeah and $500 and
then you got to get a motel and they
want a nice motel they want the [ __ ]
Palmer house in downtown Chicago which
is $275 a night a day and night $275
plus tax
that's kind of steep yeah it was what's
what's a low end of the range the low
end is motel 6 and no what about the
girls what's the least the girl was
charged for this the least 20 bucks I
bucks
cuz she as bad as I wanted she wants it
too and she's clean though if she's not
a ho on the street she's not [ __ ] 197
guys every day yeah you know she's a
good woman she's just a sexologist yeah
she wants it every day - do you uh do
you prefer this lifestyle where you have
your choice of female every night or
being married I preferred choice of
females I'd like to get married - you
know I don't think there's nothing wrong
with having kids you know and raise a
family that's a beautiful thing have you
had relationships with women that or not
yeah yeah and how those been they they
weren't very good yeah I mean it's a lot
of the women that you'll you'll pick up
are addicted to drugs
some are yeah if they are I know danger
you know if they're crackheads or
something that the one thing they want
they don't give a
about you they want that rock a crack
that's what they really want
have you been robbed before by them no
I've never been robbed
yeah never I was in the Marine Corps
eight years so I can pretty well handle
myself and any kind of physical
situation yeah but uh you know when I
meet a woman I can read her real quick
you know she's a dope addict you know
dangerous signs come up for me cuz she's
using dope she's [ __ ] around whatever
heeler swinging dick in town and she
probably got some kind of disease or
something who knows but I figure it out
all right well sympathy thank you so
much for talking with me and being so
open and and good luck with everything
from here
yeah wanna go let's go get some beer now
let's go get you some beer man
all right
you